foreign
nature this week we have the top two
pieces are
an editorial how nature contributed to
science's discriminatory Legacy we want
to acknowledge and learn from our
history and this is as you might imagine
that kind of the kind of thing that
everyone is being expected to do now I
apologize for the uh the fact that our
forebears were not moderns who
understood all of the things about
bigotry that moderns understand and the
second piece in nature this week is in
the in the basically their review of
this week's most important scientific
things that are happening and that
nature itself published
is worldview to set transgender policy
look to the evidence
policy debates concerning transgender
people are embroiled in the culture wars
let data and science not politicians
guide laws this written by someone known
as Paisley Cara the second article
to set transgender transgender policy
look to the evidence
begins
uh as follows in March the U.S state of
Utah passed a law barring transgender
girls from high school girls Sports it
defines sex as quote the condition of
being male or female determined by an
individual's genetics and Anatomy at
Birth and prohibits those of quote male
sex end quote from competing against
another school and a girls team
and this piece by again Paisley Cara
um
proceeds to
make a number of arguments that claim to
be relying on data and Science and in
this piece there is literally no
definition of sex
no purportedly scientific explanation
for how humans unique among all animals
can supposedly unique among all mammals
can supposedly change their sex
apparently no understanding of the
organizational effects of hormones the
author for instance seems to believe
that hormones only work activationally
and just a you know brief
endocrinological aside here
one way of categorizing the effects of
hormones is activational versus
organizational and most hormones have
both types of effects an activational
effect is one which when exposed to the
hormone the system that is that can
respond to it and therefore the body in
which it lives the individual in which
it lives responds immediately to the
effect of that hormone that is
activational it is basically the body is
activated by the exposure to the hormone
then there are organizational effects
which is to say early in development or
at other moments in development as new
systems are being laid down during
development exposure to the hormone
basically sets things in process such
that once exposed things are set in
process which can never be undone and
it's these organizational effects of
things like sex steroid hormones
especially testosterone but also of
estrogens which are widely almost
universally I think ignored and
certainly ignored by the author of this
piece which gets such a highlight
position in nature this week when they
talk about whether or not you could
actually be truly truly turn into the
other sex
the fact is that if you went through
puberty as a male
you cannot undo all of that simply by
taking uh cross-sex hormones or or even
by taking puberty blockers because many
of the organizational effects of
testosterone you actually underwent in
utero and in early childhood so it
strikes me here that
um
the reality is even worse than you're
portraying it and you you hint at it
here okay
um
you cannot be trying not to get out of
control you cannot have both arguments
you cannot pretend that the only impacts
are activational yes right and thereby
say well if we change your hormone
profile we've changed you into the other
sex
and also say that it is important that
people transition early right that we
cannot afford to delay a transition
because that will have permanent impacts
on the people who um who don't get the
treatment certainly so the point is if
it is true and it is true that blocking
puberty uh has an important impact than
it is because there are organizational
effects which you then cannot pretend uh
have been eliminated by some late in
life treatment that's exactly right
purely contradictory that's exactly
right I think that's that's very
important and uh just to to reiterate
also the point I made which is that the
organizational effects of testosterone
do not do not the first time that they
rear their heads is not in puberty right
right that they begin in utero uh with
basically beginning the process of the
formulation of primary sex
characteristics and also there's another
surge of basically sex differentiation
and I think it's toddlerhoods from
somewhere around like two to three years
if I remember correctly I didn't go back
and look exactly so I may have that a
little bit off and then there is a
period of time in
um you know after toddlerhood but sort
of Early Childhood through what we would
think of as like Elementary School in
early middle school years uh at least as
far as schooling goes here in the U.S
where uh the sex hormones the sex story
hormones aren't that active but it's not
that they haven't already been so and
you cannot undo organizational effects
can you mitigate the activational
effects of something by taking that
something away for sure you can in fact
possibly reverse it entirely but
testosterone estrogens and many other
hormones as well don't simply have
activation effects so the argument the
argument falls apart this in a piece
that claims
um that what it wants us to be doing is
again to look at the sub headline and
you can show us again that Zach it's
going to be a little while before I ask
you to screenshot again
um
is that we he wants
I I think I think this person Paisley
yeah Paisley
I know honestly know
um Paisley wants data and science not
politicians to guide laws well well
Paisley I got bad news for you then
because uh you can cherry pick all of
the crap articles that you want and you
did so in this piece and that does not
change the fact that sex in animals is
binary and in mammals uh you we do not
change sex and this does not this does
not belie the evidence uh the existence
of intersex people very occasionally
that's development due to developmental
anomalies nor to very very occasional
trans people who can in order to get
better alignment between their perceived
sex and their actual sex try to do
everything they can to live as the sex
that they are not but they will never be
the sex that they are not
again it's somewhat logically worse than
this because as you and I have pointed
out many times
transness exists in many cultures it is
real it is extremely rare but the fact
that it exists that it is apparently not
the product of some sort of modern
Distortion of the world means that uh
obviating the activational effects isn't
even necessary for Trans people to play
their role and live out a transitioned
life you mean the organizational effects
it either frankly but I guess my point
would be we have modern tools right we
can supplement your testosterone for
example should you want that
it is apparently not necessary to
transness what transness has been right
it is a modern uh opportunity that is
apparently not fundamental here right we
cannot fully change the uh the
organizational effects we have some
ability to mitigate the activational
effect but none of that is necessary and
certainly surgery even less so
so I I think the problem is like
um all dishonest political movements
trans activists want the benefit of part
of an argument and they want to ignore
the corollaries of it and that's right
this is just simply not how logic works
it doesn't belong in nature for one
thing yeah in in the journal Nature yeah
yeah and and of course nature who
presumably wrote the headline not
Paisley Kara
um is claiming that this is the argument
that comes from science when it's
exactly the opposite you know the claim
is don't do the politics do the science
when what the trans activists are doing
is the politics not the science they're
doing exactly the thing that they are
screaming about you know the tone in
this paper is not screaming I don't mean
that Paisley is screaming but there's
certainly a lot of screaming in trans
activist land and uh it is it is almost
always claiming that other people are
doing the very thing that they are doing
so
for instance um there's a reference
there's scant references at all or even
scientifically backed claims in this
in this world view piece
um but one piece that is cited is a
piece from 2019 called gender identity
non-discrimination laws and public
accommodations a review of evidence
regarding safety and privacy in public
restrooms locker rooms and changing
rooms well that sounds impressive
doesn't it I'm not going to go into it
here I made a bunch of snarky notes here
about the
fully crop statistics and the claims
that aren't backed up by even what they
show in the paper
but I will show this little bit of
sleazy language since I can't um can't
show my screen here quote from this
paper from 2019 has some Bush at all
critiques of anti-lgbt policies are
abounding fog Davis 2017 for example
argues for the abolishment of using sex
as a Criterion for separating facilities
let me say that again all right proudly
this paper is saying we are seeing an
increase in critique of anti-lgbt
policies isn't that great what is their
go-to example of an anti-lgbt policy
using sex as a Criterion for separating
facilities
sorry no and this actually reminds me
and I I don't know if we have a whole
lot that we know to say about this but
of there is a protest that happened in
Vermont today
um by an alliance that identifies as an
LGB Alliance
including people who were at the
original Stonewall riots who have been
long-term proponents of of gay rights
and increasingly now women's rights and
children's rights who see the tacking on
of the T and the Q and the pluses into
this originally movement about gay
rights as actually
not simply taking a space but actually
overturning many of the many of the
games that not just gays made but also
women have made and children as well yep
and again I mean it's uh
it is a permanent state in this style of
argument but again the idea that in one
sentence the differences between the
Sexes are so important that one must be
able to Avail themselves of
technological interventions to move from
one sex to the other in the same breath
as and isn't it uh a crime that we use
sex as a delineator for access to
facilities the point is either sex is
important and therefore it makes sense
that we would use it as a Criterion for
entering certain facilities or it isn't
important in which case what's all this
transitioning business what are you
transitioning from into right right
right yes
um yeah no the the hypocrisy and
incoherence is is Skin Deep Well it's
not even it's something else it is a
habitual desire to have part but not all
of a logical argument right yeah it is a
it is a surgical separation of a logical
argument from some of its logical
consequences and that is evidence of bad
faith I mean it's just simply is yes and
this is also a corollary we have talked
about the fact that you own the
downsides of your own arguments and this
is one of these things which is if
you're going to you know invoke sex in
one sentence in order to justify uh
intervention for transitions you can't
then decry its existence in the second
right right that's one or the other
[Music]
foreign